-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy, Grammy and Tony
award-winning composer,
playwright, and the creator
of hit Broadway shows "Hamilton"
and "In the Heights."
His feature directorial debut,
"tick, tick...BOOM!"
is now on Netflix.
And you can hear his new music
in Disney's "Encanto,"
which is in theaters everywhere
tomorrow.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Welcome to
the Family Madrigal ♪
♪ The home of
-♪ We're on our way ♪
-♪ Where all the people are
fantastical and magical ♪
♪ I'm part of
the Family Madrigal ♪
-Oh, my gosh, it's them!
What are the gifts?
-I can't remember all the gifts!
-But I don't know who is who!
-Alright, alright, relax!
-It is physically impossible
to relax!
-Tell us everything!
What are your powers?
-Just tell us
what everyone can do!
-And that's why
coffee's for grown-ups.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome
back to the show,
our friend, Lin-Manuel Miranda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
-A lot a lot has happened.
-A lot has happened.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Whoa, thank you. You're so kind.
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Well.
-So, one thing
I want to ask about, you know,
doing a Disney film like this,
a lot of pressure
insofar as, "How are kids
going to like it?"
You were saying backstage
that you did "Moana,"
that was the first movie
your oldest ever saw.
-Yes, I found out
I got the job on "Moana" --
I Interviewed for it,
and I found out I got the job
the same day we found out
we were going to be parents.
So it's all mixed up.
Like, "Moana" is, weirdly,
my oldest son's sibling.
-I would imagine,
when he saw "Moana"
and liked it, that's great.
But he also hadn't seen
anything else, right?
-Yeah, he had nothing
to compare it to.
-So he might've just been like,
"Look,
I just like
the idea of movies."
-Yes.
Yes, this concept of -- of
images on a screen is --
-So, now he's a little older.
I'm assuming, between
this and "Encanto,"
he's seen some other movies.
-He has serious sophistication.
-Yeah, he might have
some standards now.
So you must -- Were you
more stressful
when you showed him this one?
-100%.
Well, you have to understand,
also,
I wrote this
during the pandemic,
so they had to hear
every phase of "Encanto"
as I was writing the songs,
as Daddy is talking to himself
in the corner, singing...
♪ Welcome to
the Family Madrigal ♪
But I also have --
I mean, I have --
I have a 3-year-old
and a 7-year-old.
They are the greatest
beta testers in the world.
There were moments
in early drafts
that were too scary for them.
My 3-year-old has
the immortal quote.
At one point, he grabs me
and he goes, "Daddy,
can we watch a kids' movie?"
[ Laughter ]
And I went back to the director.
I was like,
"Okay, that seems too scary.
[ Laughter ]
We got to go back
to the drawing board."
But, yeah, it was great.
-Stephanie Beatriz.
Stephanie Beatriz is
a voice in this.
-Mirabel is our Disney hero.
-And so I know we are both
huge fans of
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
-Yes.
-And it must've been so great
to work with her on this.
I know you worked with her
on "In the Heights" as well.
-Absolutely.
Well, I think one of
the great cosmic jokes is
that Stephanie became famous
on a show
where her voice is
two octaves down
and in a monotone.
-Yes.
-And Detective Rosa Diaz.
When you actually meet her,
she's like, "Hi!"
[ Laughter ]
And she has, like,
one of the bubbliest,
most musical voices
you'll ever hear.
So I knew that Stephanie.
I met Stephanie
in our early 20s, mid 20s,
when she was doing
Quiara's play,
like, very experimental,
off- off-, off-
off-Broadway play.
So it's been a joy to --
It was amazing
when she had her sort of
nationwide prominence
on "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
And then, you know,
to work with her on this,
like, where I'm writing
Disney songs
and she's the Disney,
like, hero,
I'm like, "She's in a club
with, like, Jodi Benson
and Anika Noni Rose
and Lea Salonga
and all these, like,
Disney heroines."
So, we would text each other
while we were recording
her songs,
like, "Can you believe this?
Can you believe this?"
[ Laughter ]
It was great.
-So, at this point,
it must be cool to have,
like, a good
working relationship
with something
as iconic as Disney,
which it introduces
so many children
to musical theater, I feel.
-Yeah, 100%.
I think a lot
about Howard Ashman,
who was Alan Menken's
great lyricist and partner
and really, I think,
is responsible
for ushering in that, like,
second golden age of Disney.
He wrote the lyrics
for "Little Mermaid"
and "Beauty and the Beast,"
and really just, sort of
brought musical theater
into animation.
It was like, "This is
how it works, guys."
And just was -- I was
really inspired by that.
And so, you know, when
I started working on "Encanto,"
I just said, "I want to be there
from the beginning,"
so that the songs and the scenes
can kind of
go as seamlessly into each other
as possible."
And you know, it's been --
I'm really proud
of "Encanto" and
the work we did together.
-And I'm sure, when you work
on a musical
on a Broadway stage,
you see it at every level.
There's no moment where
you're, you know, blown away
by what happened
between the night before
and you know, the morning after.
-Right.
-With animation,
it must be so thrilling
the first time you see,
like, a song you wrote.
-Yeah.
This is the movie
I've seen the least
that I have worked on.
Also, because I think -- because
we were working from home,
Disney security
was even more intense.
So I would be like, "Can I just
get minutes 45 to 48?
'Cause I have a write
a song for that?
Can I see it, please?"
And -- But it was also --
what's so thrilling
about writing for animation is
that they can move
at the speed of thought.
So, there's a song in the movie
called "Surface Pressure,"
where, you know,
this character is singing
about how she feels nervous
and what's under the surface.
So, again, I cut to my kids
worried about me,
and me in the corner,
being like...
"Nervous," "surface,"
"how big the iceberg is."
[ Laughter ]
"Cerberus?"
And just as many "nervous"
rhymes as I can get,
and I write the song.
And then, when it comes back,
the animation goes there.
It can show you Cerberus.
It can show
how big the iceberg is.
And it can move
at the speed of thought,
which is just thrilling
when you're a lyricist.
-That's really exciting.
I want to --
I'm very excited to talk to you
about your directorial debut.
We're going to be right back
with more
from Lin-Manuel Miranda.